after more than a year of lockdowns the
bad weather was not going to stop
americans from heading out this holiday
weekend
aaa says 37 million are expected to
travel more than 50 miles this weekend
that's a 60 percent
increase over last year when much of the
country was still under lockdown orders
and that's despite the highest gasoline
prices on memorial day
in seven years the average price of a
gallon of regular is now just north of
three dollars
the travel surge is due in large part to
the increasing number of people who are
now vaccinated against the coronavirus
just over half of all americans have had
at least one dose
of the vaccine just over 40 percent are
fully vaccinated
michael george has more on how americans
might be spending this holiday weekend
michael good morning
jeff good morning this memorial day
weekend is really the first true test
since much of the nation has reopened
and from coast to coast some health
officials are set up and ready to
vaccinate people
even where they plan to relax this
weekend
going to the beach this weekend new york
health officials mobile vaccination
van will be there too it was perfectly
situated for marijuana and her daughters
i was waiting for them to do it so the
sooner i heard they are doing for 12 and
14 years
i was like okay why not the effort to
meet people where they live
made the difference for david mccallum
because they're here
and someone knocked on my door and said
it must be meant to be let me go get a
shot
bringing the vaccine to people is what's
going to get us to where we need to be
just about half of u.s adults are still
not fully vaccinated
but it's within distance of president
biden's goal of 70 percent vaccinated
adults by july 4th
we have to reach those who are not
vaccinated and make it as easy as
possible for them to get protected
it's become a place by place state by
state process
i'm proud to say that 66 percent
of virginia adults have had their first
shot
virginia will hit president biden's goal
vermont leads the nation with almost 50
percent of its population
fully vaccinated and with numbers edging
higher
so are the numbers of people hitting the
road this weekend
as more people get vaccinated they're
becoming more comfortable with the idea
of travel but there's still some travel
hesitancy
and with good reason according to dr
eileen marty
i am very concerned about people who are
not vaccinated
who think that because the rates are
down
they're off the hook they don't need to
get vaccinated and they're not going to
get sick
they're wrong they could very well get
sick they could very well end up in the
hospital
they could die and heading into summer
the centers for disease control issued
new summer camp deadlines for children
those vaccinated will not have to wear
masks at camps
at this point only children 12 years or
older are eligible to be vaccinated
though medical trials are underway that
will help determine if
most children can be vaccinated michelle
all right michael george thank you so
much